gedämpfte hoffnungen bundesregierung
länder chefs und chefinnen sehen vor dem
corona gipfel morgen kaum eine chance
für lockerungen chinas triumph mit der
größten freihandelszone der welt den
asien-pazifik-raum punktet peking gegen
die america first politik der usa
gekrönter champion lewis hamilton wird
zum siebten mal formel-1-weltmeister und
stellt michael schumachers titel rekord
ein
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend am sonntag
willkommen bei den nachrichten mit sport
und norbert könig und die hälfte des
novembers ist rum ohne dass die korona
zahlen in deutschland merklich nach
unten gegangen wären nur die kurve der
neuansteckungen ist ein bisschen flacher
geworden
was aber heißt das nun für uns für
restaurants theater schulen darüber
beraten morgen bund und ländern
nicole diekmann seit zwei wochen ist die
gastronomie runtergefahren restaurants
dürfen nur noch außer haus verkaufen
sie könnten jetzt als klassenzimmer
genutzt werden schlägt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister vor ich weiß
dass in sehr vielen gaststätten und
hotels die im augenblick nicht arbeiten
können solche möglichkeiten vorhanden
sind
es gibt auch kommunale kulturzentren die
man dafür nehmen könnte insgesamt geht
es darum unseren schülern den unterricht
zu geben die sie brauchen aber
gleichzeitig die schutzmaßnahmen zu
optimieren eine ungewöhnliche idee die
schulen sollen offen bleiben anders als
im frühjahr daran will man unbedingt
festhalten und gleichzeitig die
infektionszahlen weiter und stärker
senken
in jedem fall werden wir morgen in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz kaum grünes
licht geben können
die massnahmen vorzeitig abzufedern oder
abzumildern oder lockerungen einzuführen
das geben die zahlen ganz einfach nicht
her
vielmehr müssen wir schauen dass wir
jetzt in der zweiten hälfte dieses
november lockt bei uns auch noch mal
nachschärfen die zahlen senken und dabei
das vertrauen der bevölkerung nicht
verlieren das ist der balance akt den
die politik in den kommenden wochen
schaffen will
wenn wir einen nächsten schritt machen
sollten dann wäre es am besten die
kontakt beschränkungen weiter etwas zu
verschärfen und wir müssen auch jetzt
einfach die geduld haben nach zwei
wochen dass wir jetzt die nächsten tage
und die ergebnisse des lok bei uns
anschauen bevor wir auch wirklich alle
wieder so ein bisschen verrückt machen
die gespräche zwischen kanzleramt und
ministerpräsidenten beginnen morgen um
14 uhr
morgen also das spitzentreffen zur
halbzeitbilanz theo koll in berlin
nach dem was wir gerade gehört haben
sieht es ja nach ablauf dieses monats er
nicht nach einer rückkehr zur normalität
aus oder absolut richtig und darauf
bereitet uns die politik gerade gezielt
vor
die kanzlerin spricht davon dass uns
weitere harte monate bevorstünden der
wirtschaftsminister spricht sogar von
starken einschränkungen bis ostern
die ursprüngliche anlage hat aber kurz
scheint jedenfalls vergangenheit auch
wenn man morgen wohl noch keine
verlängerung beschließen wird dafür ist
die datenlage einfach noch zu unsicher
aus teilnehmerkreisen hören wir dass es
möglicherweise eine weitere verschärfung
bei den erlaubten kontakten in der
öffentlichkeit geben könnte statt zehn
menschen ist jetzt eine deutlich
kleinere zahl im gespräch um
einigermaßen normale feiertage haben zu
können wären dann weitere maßnahmen
nötig so jedenfalls die haltung vieler
in den vorbereitungs runden für das
morgige treffen
morgen abend wird mir mehr vielen dank
theo koll schauen wir auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen die sonntags immer etwas
niedriger legen weil am wochenende in
der regel nicht alle daten übermittelt
werden
das robert koch institut meldet 16 1947
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 930 mehr als am vergangenen sonntag
107 neue todesfälle kamen in verbindung
mit kogit 19 hinzu alles so corona krise
alle entwicklungen zum virus in
deutschland aber auch weltweit haben wir
für sie in der zdf- heute- app
zusammengestellt in unserem corona blog
us-präsident trump hat seinen
kontrahenten joe biden erstmals als
wahlsieger bezeichnet dabei aber seine
betrugsvorwürfe wiederholt er hat
gewonnen weil die wahl manipuliert war
schrieb trump auf twitter
später dann stellt er in einem weiteren
tweet klar beiden habe nur in den augen
der fake news medien gewonnen er donald
trump bestehe gar nichts ein
in asien und der pazifikregion ist die
größte freihandelszone der welt
entstanden 15 staaten um china japan und
australien haben das abkommen
unterzeichnet
mitten im handelskrieg mit den usa baut
peking so seine position im pazifik raum
aus und festigt dort seine
vormachtstellung vor den usa und europa
ulf röller berichtet in chinesischen
hauptnachrichten feiern den
freihandelspakt wie einen nationalen
triumph einen triumph im kampf mit
amerika um einfluss in der region
ministerpräsident kan spricht von licht
und hoffnung in dunklen zeiten eine
feierliche zeremonie als rahmen für die
unterzeichnung des abkommens wegen der
korona krise waren aber die meisten
regierungschefs nur per video konferenz
zugeschaltet
umso eindeutiger die botschaft an die
welt die globale wirtschaft sei mit
enormen herausforderungen will der
pandemie konfrontiert erklärt der
vietnamesische ministerpräsident
der neue pakt sei ein gutes signal für
die wirtschaft dem freihandelspakt
gehören neben china 14 weitere
asiatisch-pazifische staaten an
2,2 milliarden menschen leben in diesem
wirtschaftsraum der ein drittel der
weltwirtschaftsleistung umfasst vor
allem werden solle verringert und
handelsregeln festgelegt china erweitert
mit dem freihandelspakt seinen einfluss
in der region peking nutzt eben aus dass
präsident trump mit seiner america first
politik viele länder verprellt hat im
duell der weltmächte haben chinas
machthaber erneut gepunktet
die asien pazifik region ist heute
wirtschaftlich enger zusammengerückt
auch dies ist eine antwort auf die
korona krise auch an diesem sonntag
haben in belarus wieder tausende
menschen gegen machthaber lukaschenko
protestiert
in der hauptstadt minsk lösten die
sicherheitskräfte kundgebungen an
mehreren orten gewaltsam auf und nahm
hunderte menschen fest
die polizei ging dabei auch massiv gegen
demonstranten vor die an den tod eines
regierungskritiker seien
heute ist volkstrauertag ein tag des
gedenkens zu ehren der opfer des
nationalsozialismus und der weltkriege
dieses jahr ist er der
deutsch-britischen freundschaft gewidmet
75 jahre nach kriegsende bei der
zentralen feier waren erstmals
mitglieder des britischen königshauses
zu gast thronfolger prinz charles und
seine frau camilla jetzt schneider
berichtet es ist ein großes zeichen der
versöhnung auf einladung von
bundespräsident steinmeier nimmt prinz
charles an der gedenkfeier teil
in seiner rede im bundestag die er auf
englisch und deutsch hält betont der
britische thronfolger die lange
freundschaft und geht auf aktuelle
krisen ein
diese krisen rufen und dazu gemeinsam zu
handeln und die partnerschaft zwischen
dem vereinigten königreich und
deutschland bietet uns in dieser
hinsicht eine wichtige chance an der
neuen wache hatte prinz charles zuvor
mit seiner frau camilla einen kranz
niedergelegt der besuch hat symbolische
bedeutung gerade auch am ende der brh
exit verhandlungen
wir werden immer freunde partner und
verbündete sein lassen sie uns diese
bande zu beginn dieses neuen kapitels
rüstigen deutsch-britische versöhnung
mit blick auf eine gemeinsame zukunft
top thema im sport das natürlich die
formel 1 mit dem alles überragenden
er hat schon wieder ein stück
rennsportgeschichte geschrieben sieben
mal weltmeister
der brite macht in istanbul schon im
viertletzten rennen der saison den titel
perfekt und erreicht damit die bestmarke
von michael schumacher
kurz nachdem lewis hamilton die
ziellinie überquert hatte wurde es
emotional für alle kinder da draußen die
vom unmöglichen träumen
ihr könnt es schaffen sagt er sichtlich
gerührt über seinen funk hamilton ging
zunächst von platz sechs aus ins rennen
doch der regen sorgte für viel
durcheinander und spülte den
rekordsieger immer weiter nach vorn
knapp 20 runden vor ende setzte sich
hamilton an die spitze fuhr zu seinem
insgesamt 94
riesig und siebter
wm titel sebastian vettel heute erstmals
in der saison auf dem treppchen als
dritter hinter sergio perez der größte
ist aber lewis hamilton an diesem
emotionalen tag in istanbul
zwei treffer von timo werner beim 3 1
der dfb-auswahl in der nations league
gegen die ukraine die kritik bleibt dass
das spiel trotz der kogit 19 fälle bei
den ukrainern angegriffen wurde
der bundestrainer nach den 90 minuten
mit seiner sicht auf die korona
diskussion wir von uns aus können ja
nicht irgendein spiel absagen ich als
trainer als trainer bin natürlich auch
froh dass das spiel stattfinden keine
frage froh war joachim löw auch über die
willensstärke seiner mannschaft nach dem
rückstand drehten sané und werner mit
seinen zwei toren das spiel zugunsten
der dfb-elf am dienstag geht es gegen
spanien in sevilla um den gruppensieg
wohlgemerkt in corona risikogebiet
maximilian levy feiert bei der bahnrad
em in plowdiw seinen zweiten titel nach
dem sprint gewinnt der cottbuser auch im
keirin dem sogenannten kampfsprint levi
war auf eigene verantwortung einziger
deutscher teilnehmer im risikogebiet
bulgarien weil der verband die tiere
meldung zurückgezogen hatte hoffentlich
was er tat
duncan arbeit zum schluss das wetter
morgen meist stark bewölkt im norden
immer wieder schauer auch an den alpen
regen der aber zum nachmittag nachlässt
8 bis 13 grad
so viel von uns für den moment mehr gibt
es im heute journal um drei viertel 10
mit claus kleber
wir danken für ihre aufmerksamkeit
wünschen einen gemütlichen sonntagabend
und sagen tschüss bismarck